[Musique]
bonjour le café politique reprend donc
sur tv fil 78 toujours ici au bistrot du
théâtre à montigny le bretonneux mais
dans un format différent nous allons
dorénavant revenir sur l'actualité
l'actualité locale l'actualité nationale
à travers une revue de presse en
compagnie de trois invités il siège
aussi bien dans la majorité que dans
l'opposition dans un conseil municipal à
la région au département ou à
l'assemblée nationale voire même au
sénat aujourd'hui pour nous accompagner
sur la prochaine demi heure erwan le
gall première adjointe au maire de
maurepas conseiller communautaire
délégué de saint quentin en charge de
l'emploi et de l'insertion membre du
bureau national du parti
libéral-démocrate dangereux à vous je
l'utiliserai conseiller communautaire
d'opposition également élu d'opposition
à larry notre approvisionnement produits
parti communiste français et puis marc
lerouge président des jeunes udc des
yvelines on joue également à tous les
deux on va revenir donc à travers une
revue de presse sur l'actualité et puis
peut-être pour débuter cette déclaration
qui est rapporté par le parisien qui est
daté du 19 septembre dernier si un camp
de migrants à lucian se confirmait ce
serait une hérésie en termes de sécurité
pour les petites communes de la région
ces signes d'un journaliste jean pierre
pernaut qui réside du côté de bouffe
sienne vous en avez pensé quoi les quizz
ray de cette déclaration de cette sortie
dans la presse qui était donc dans le
parisien
cc c'est toujours pareil on pense que ce
serait mieux chez le voisin
et le plus loin possible de chez soi
donc c'est un sujet très très compliqué
les murs parisiens l'ont connu récemment
donc et du moins de ce qui en est
ressorti ça s'est passé relativement
correctement je crois qu'on peut dire
même correctement donc
il ya les inquiétudes mais il ya toutes
ces peurs qu'on essaye de susciter en
permanence qui sont une catastrophe
il ya d'autres problèmes à résoudre et à
gérer en france en ce moment que
d'attiser les environs 10 ans également
dans les médias mais déjà alors déjà je
les appelle pas les migrants qui
s'appelle les réfugiés parce que c'est
des réfugiés économiques de la guerre
ces voix-là et
et dans tout cela je pense que nos
gouvernants ont aussi une part de
responsabilité
donc
on se devrait de les accueillir de
manière
digne comme n'importe quel être humain
ce qui se passe dans certains endroits
comme à calais par exemple est
proprement scandaleux pour les réfugiés
avant tout mais également pour les
populations jeu local il faut noter si
l'élan de générosité des moreaux
patients par rapport à ça c'est aussi
faut noter un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes par des mails par des
messages par des interpellations dans la
rue voilà mais sur un autre point de vue
c'est la méthode qui va pas
l'état réquisitionne 48 heures avant un
gymnase à maurepas bon il le savait
c'était prévu depuis bien longtemps
c'est une méthode qui est complètement
irresponsable le ciel je comprends
l'inquiétude j'ai lu
l'intervention et j'ai vu d'ailleurs
dans tv filiale intervention du maire
elle est légitime elle est complètement
légitime maintenant l'état par rapport à
ça devrait réfléchir que j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir le président du sénat qui
m'a appelé pour faire un point à date et
il me dit mais vous monsieur premier
adjoint qu'est ce que vous en pensez par
rapport à ça dans l'état de fait du
fonctionnement j'y suis président
sincèrement si on prenait en charge les
migrants ou les réfugiés correctement si
nous mettions autant de la table des
gens de l'association l'associatif les
élus maires ou conseillers ou hadji
adjoint des yvelines on réfléchit
correctement ça peut bien se passer si
on fait ça part fort sage sans arrêt
permanence en disant on va les mettre ça
ne fonctionne pas vous êtes plutôt tous
d'accord en fait sur lui il ya un
problème de traitement politico 6 2 de
la question clairement enfin ce que
vient de dire erwan on impose ça vient
d'en haut et comme beaucoup de décisions
on va en parler sur d'autres sujets mais
c'est toujours la décision qui vient
d'en haut qui est imposé il faut se
rappeler une chose une personne aux
députés de la nation qui se dit patriote
qui a appelé on va répartir ça c'est
scandaleux ce sont des gens sont des
familles sont des personnes qui fuient
leur pays ont fuit jamais volontairement
son pays
le gros problème à calais c'est la
concentration dans des conditions
absolument déplorable à grande synthe le
maire a essayé d'organiser à essayer de
faire un quand ça se passe plutôt bien
il ya des difficultés il ya des
problèmes mais ça se passe plutôt bien
jean pierre pernaut qui est censé être
un journaliste est en fait il défend sa
paroisse et y voit simplement qui va y
avoir il utilise un vocabulaire
anxiogène quand migrants devant chez lui
attention c'est plutôt devant chez lui
devant les légendes louveciennes c'est
plutôt ça son discours mais on veut
toujours reporté la chose ailleurs mais
à un moment c'est plus possible il ya un
président de région qui lance une
pétition qui demande à ce que ce soit
pas chez lui donc c'est toujours avec
voilà on veut déplacer le problème on
pourra déplacer le problème autant qu'on
veut il ya des gens qui fuient leur pays
et des gens qui fuient des problèmes des
guerres et qui fuit qui veulent sauver
leur vie on met pas un enfant de 3 ans
sur un bateau pour aller recueillir 300
400 500 euros d'allocations le même pour
sauver sa vie il faut s'organiser il
faut que l'état s'organise avec les élus
locaux avec les associations faut
arrêter que ça descende comme ça 48
heures avant mais je pense qu'il faut
accueillir les migrants et
ces 80 migrants 90 grand amour pas ça
pas poser problème en une centaine de
migrants c'est simplement une question
d'organisation mais il faut le faire
parce que je pense qu'un jour on aura
peut-être des comptes à rendre aux
générations futures il faut leur
expliquer pourquoi on a laisser les gens
mourir à nos portes vous avez évoqué la
région tout à l'heure justement la
présidente de la région ile de france
qu'on voit beaucoup en ce moment fait
beaucoup de déclarations beaucoup
d'annoncés en cette rentrée et il ya eu
un chiffre un chiffre c'est un million
un million par jour c'est ce que
représente la fraude dans les transports
en commun franciliens selon la
présidente valérie pécresse elle a
développé un nouveau plan dorénavant de
la de répression et plus par exemple
usagers 200 billets devra justifier de
son identité et en cas de refus il
pourra être retenu jusqu'à 4h dorénavant
par les agents parce que ça c'est une
bonne idée
ça fait partie des écrans de fumée c'est
à dire que on agite quelque chose qui
est un problème réel qu'il faut résoudre
certes les problèmes majeurs des
franciliens c'est quand même les
transports c'est pas la fraude justement
leur valérie pécresse explique que ça
permettra de récupérer l'argent qui est
perdu pour mieux financer le transport
ça c'est la rénovation des rames ça
c'est peanuts par rapport aux besoins
qui lie à la majeure partie des gens qui
prennent
le train savent très bien que
les problèmes
récurrents sont présents pratiquement
tous qu'aucun événement etc on est ici à
côté d'un axe
moi je suis élu à trappes il ya des
dizaines de milliers de véhicules qui
passent tous les jours il ya des
dizaines j'ai misé 10 qui complète de
camions qui passent tous les jours et on
a une gare de triage qui est en
qui n'est plus utilisée
alors que par le fai re routage aurait
moyen de lutter contre la pollution
atmosphérique donc on nous a fait tout
un truc sur la côte 21 très bien tout
s'est bien passé c'était merveilleux et
en même temps monsieur macron mettez des
bus sur les routes pour qui est encore
plus de pollution atmosphérique
c'est d'une logique
incroyable donc les problèmes des
transports à mon avis sont beaucoup plus
et c'est pas avec ça qu'on va
permettre de rectifier le tir c'est un
sujet mais là encore un écran de fumée
de plus votre cerveau alors premier
point de désaccord c'est bien qu'il y en
a quelques-uns bien sûr
je crois que la plus grosse fraude ans
qui existent au niveau des transports
c'est l'état de délabrement dans lequel
a laissé la gauche les transports en ile
de france ça c'est le premier hold up
très clairement je crois que si on avait
une un service de qualité avec un prix
en corrélation avec le service on ne
serait pas là voilà je pense que c'est
une bonne mesure très clairement
les fraudeurs ce n'est plus possible
c'est 330 millions 360 365 avion a mis à
part sur l'île de sein ce
qui est faux selon les chiffres de la
cour des comptes nous voilà donc ce qui
est parce qu il est extraordinairement
lourd il faut enrayer sa évidemment mais
je crois sincèrement que
il aurait fallu prendre ce problème il
ya un héritage évidemment mais depuis de
nombreuses années on n'a rien fait avec
les transports à rien du tout et quand
vous avez des gens qui payent très cher
carte orange en finlande à leur passe
navigo cette année
qu'ils attendent un service et moi je
suis pour l'ouverture de la concurrence
d'ailleurs je l'avais défendu aux
régionales il faut absolument ouvrir à
la concurrence
voilà ça c'est un état de fait après
nous devons aussi ouvrir
et analysés par rapport aux gens qui
sont plus démunis un réellement mais je
ne constate d'ailleurs que ce soit ces
gens là qui fraudent voilà parce que je
connais aussi un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui me disent mais tu sais je
fraude où il ya de la fraude parce que
la qualité n'est pas requis et puis il
ya d'autres moyens aussi bien vous savez
des portiques loire là c'est que ce
qu'il y ait au ferroviaire mme après au
niveau des bus et c'est bon ça
s'améliore petitement mais j'insiste
bien le vrai hold up est la vraie fraude
c'est la non gestion de ce parc depuis
des années il n'autoriserait sur la
concurrence la mise en concurrence
c'est une vraie problématique qui touche
les franciliens les saint quentinois
tout le monde prend ses transports en
commun donc ans mais déjà un petit peu
surtout sur l'héritage de la gauche donc
l'héritage c'est pas toujours uniquement
celui qui vient juste avant un parce que
même si la gauche va essayer we've à 17
ans mais
regardez bien il ya eu des efforts sur
les transports très conséquents qui ont
été faits insuffisant d'accord mais très
conséquents qui ont été faits le pass
navigo unique c'était quand même une
avancée très positive
donc il ya eu aussi des choses de faites
que ce soit pas suffisant mais est ce
que c'est la concurrence alors
certainement pas n'est certainement pas
la concurrence mais on va on va dépasser
sur un autre domaine par exemple pour
bien comprendre la concurrence quand on
a privatisé gdf ça fait quoi ça et c'est
augmentation du gaz
pour qui pour les actionnaires pas pour
un meilleur service donc ça c'est un
vieux sujet du libéralisme financier pas
économique parce que je fais bien la
distinction entre les deux choses la
concurrence six années quelque chose ça
se saurait en fait les ententes entre
les opérateurs téléphoniques par exemple
est ce que c'est normal etc etc on voit
bien que la concurrence si c'était la
solution et bien cela a été prouvé et
l'expérience tout montre que c'est au
contraire
juste plusieurs choses moi je suis aussi
élu au transport dans ma commune et il
se trouve que mon maire et
vice-présidente des transports de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge des
transports donc je connais très bien la
question des transports le pass navigo
unique c'est une amélioration pour trois
millions et demi de personnes qui ont vu
leur abonnement baissé et à 400000
personnes dont une est deux qui ont vu
leurs abonnements augmente et valérie
pécresse a dit qu'elle ne revenait pas
dessus elle n'est pas revenue sur le
tarif unique le problème c'est le
montant parce que l'équilibré financier
il n'était pas à 70 euros comme ça a été
fixé et à 85 euros donc elle l'a laissé
à 70 d'aucuns diront qu'elle augmentait
de 3 euros il a fallu trouver les 300
millions d'euros qui manquaient c'est
une décision sur 17 ans qui a été prise
trois mois avant les élections
régionales bon
on peut penser ce qu'on veut il ya un
plan quinquennal qui a été lancé par
l'ancienne majorité de 12 milliards
d'euros de rénovation des transports
trois mois avant les élections
régionales il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont faites trois mois avant les
élections régionales là où je suis
d'accord avec vous les transports sont
en état catastrophique les bus les
métros les tramways les trains ont dû
tramway en seine saint denis vous prenez
les trains chez nous tout simplement je
rencontre souvent la sncf ils font avec
des moyens dérisoires les essaye de
faire leur métier le problème c'est que
on n'est pas habitué à une chose mais
valérie pécresse je suis dit je suis pas
dupe à républicain
elle tient ses promesses en fait elle a
pris des engagements de lutter contre la
fraude de rénover les transports en
commun et ça va chercher partout alors
là elle est sur le plan anti fraude ne
faut pas oublier qu'avant elle est allée
voir le gouvernement en leur disant
nettement prenez vos responsabilités
il nous manque et 300 millions d abonnés
vos responsabilités et elle a obtenu du
gouvernement 150 200 millions d'euros il
a fallu augmenter de 3 euros il faut
rénover les rames un million d'euros par
jour ça parle pas forcément aux gens
trois cent mille trois cent cinquante
millions d'euros par an c'est à peu près
40 rames neuves de métro c'est à peu
près 400 buts c'est à peu près six rames
de train donc ça commence par là ça
commence par un on ne peut pas accepter
que les gens
ils prennent le train ou le métro bus
tous les jours ils sont dans des
bétaillères et c'est juste pas possible
et on peut pas accepter ça donc ça
commence on va aller chercher l'argent
partout où il est il faut lutter contre
la fraude pour ensuite aménager la
sécurité et pour faire en sorte enfin on
aider les transports descend la fraude
c'est 8 à 9% de fraude estimée par la
cour des comptes c'est 1% à londres à
new york à bruxelles c'est pas des pays
qu'ils vous sont totalement déconnectés
donc ça fait partie d'un panel complet
et je vous permet de compléter que en
plus le prix du titre de transport dans
ces pays sont plus près des 50 % du coût
de production au point de vue du prix de
revient du du vrai coup transports les
livres etc ou de transports alors que
nous on est plus près des 30 % donc
toute une histoire de prix non plus il
ya la qualité les gens c'est pas
acceptable personne ne sait réagir et ce
non pas qu'on va avancer dans la revue
de presse
non mais
j'ai forcément énormément de choses à
rajouter le
la qualité est effectivement et puis moi
je peux que vous le dire parce que voilà
donc
vous l'avez le passé la réalité on
constate les retards les trains annulés
et sicav etc mais c'est tout aussi toute
une politique
qui a été de porter atteinte pour ce qui
concerne le ferret à la sncf puisque
aujourd'hui la sncf
à des compagnies de bus pour
concurrencer les trains passer c'est du
grand n'importe quoi la problématique
des transports doit être envisagée dans
son ensemble oui il ya une
complémentarité avec nécessaire c'est
normal qu'ils aient les camions c'est
pas normal qu'ils en aient autant donc
on fait les grands discours et puis
derrière voilà
juste un dernier sujet sur lequel je
vous faire réagir kiki ressorti aussi
dans la presse et qui concerne le
département des yvelines et puis ensuite
je vous demanderais ce que vous vous
retenez de l'actualité de ces derniers
jours et vous pourrez échanger sur sur
ça tout ce qui revient aussi dans la
presse dans la presse locale c'est ce
rapprochement des deux départements
yvelines et hauts-de-seine il ya un nom
qui est sorti ces derniers jours ces
sites alios c'est cette nouvelle société
d'économie mixte d'aménagement des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine nouvelle
étape concrète du rapprochement entre
les deux départements et là je vais
commencer avec voulu que miserait tout
simplement parce qu'il n'ya plus d'élus
de gauche dans cette assemblée
départementale à droite donc il ya plus
vraiment d'opposition vous en tant
qu'élu de gauche un rapprochement entre
deux départements est ce que là ça peut
permettre de faire des économies quand
on sait que dans le département des
yvelines les différentes taxes
saint quentinois les yvelinois les
reçoivent en ce moment ont augmenté la
part du département a augmenté le
département a dû augmenter les impôts ce
que l'on va faire des économies à terme
avec un rapprochement avec les
hauts-de-seine par exemple il a dû ça a
été un choix de sa part
faut savoir quand même que ce
département est quand même un des plus
riches de france et que c'est un des
moins endettée de france également les
augmentations sont justifiées par le
baisse des dotations par la baisse des
dotations de l'état ça c'est ce que dit
le président du conseil départemental et
puis c'est ses élus la baisse est réelle
elle est anormale et inqualifiable à une
époque où on a besoin d'investir
davantage sur tout un tas de sujets et
notamment par rapport à nos populations
les plus en difficulté mais par contre
qu'il faille faire des économies oui
mais on peut faire des coopérations est
ce qu'on a besoin de fusion c'est un
problème de riche les yvelines avec les
hauts-de-seine et puis les autres qui
crèvent dans leur coin donc on crée des
superstructures comme ça mais la volonté
on nous dit alors juste faire des
économies on te faire des économies
autrement qui est des coopérations pour
faire des économies qui est des
coopérations parce qu'effectivement
quand on habite à sartrouville on est
aussi proche de cormeilles-en-parisis
que que des hauts-de-seine et et cetera
dans nos campagnes on est proche de
l'eure et loir où des proches de leurs
bons donc qu'il y ait des cons
créer des coopérations mais ça existe
déjà mais pas de fusion ça cette fusion
va servir à rien c'est pas ça qui fera
baisser la facture pour les impôts dans
l'essentiel c'est cette fusion c'est une
fusion dogmatique en encore une fois
entre problèmes de riches qui veulent se
regrouper entre eux pour éviter
la coopération avec d'autres on a besoin
développer le vivre ensemble ça répond
pas du tout à cela alors ni au niveau
des services rendus puisque on est dans
un département qui sert le qui rendent
moins de services par rapport à sa
richesse ses quatre ans vous étiez
d'accord ouvriers mais là vous n'êtes
plus d'accord jusqu'à la corse à l'heure
où il ya plusieurs sujets et procéder à
l'augmentation des impôts le les
yvelines ont vu leur baisse comme
beaucoup département mais encore plus
parce que les yvelines ont le trip
l'inconvénient d'être un département car
très faible de très faibles frais de
fonctionnement à une très faible
endettement et donc c'est un département
riche bon moi je rencontre tous les
jours je pense vous rencontrez aussi on
en rencontre tous des gens tous les
jours qu'ils sont pas assez riches pas
l'impression d'être des riches et pour
autant on a été sanctionné la
péréquation la dgf qui baisse de 90% et
pendant ce temps là et il faut trouver
des ressources donc je pense que le
budget c'est une procès c'est autre
chose maintenant la fusion je suis un
peu d'accord avec vous pourquoi
fusionner moi comme ça je suis dubitatif
je suis pas contre mais pour quoi faire
il dort dans quel but ce que je constate
c'est qu'on va recentrer le coeur vers
l'est et la ruralité dans tout ça moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'explique comment
nous nos agriculteurs comment les
communes rurales vont vivre 7,7 ce
rapprochement moi je suis prêt à tout
entendre mais encore une fois on rajoute
des strates regrouper des établissements
publics pourquoi pas si c'est pour faire
des économies mais j'ai rarement de
jusqu'à maintenant des regroupements qui
ont amené des économies
j'en ai pas vus erwan le gall oregon des
accords sociaux ajouté un petit peu la
première chose c'est pas grave d'être
riche et c'est pas grave d'être dans une
commune de riches et les riches dans ce
que j'ai dit non mais c'est un constat
je sais bien qu'il des communes riches
et je constate une nouvelle fois qu'une
commune enfin une un département bien
gérée pas endettée est bien la seule
récompense qu'il a c'est qu'il est
sanctionné d'accord voilà et d'ailleurs
je fais une petite parenthèse c'est que
bah oui mais il est sanctionné sur sa
bonne gestion n'en ai vu sanctionné
comme les autres tout le monde à névez
ne soit pas au même n'a pas les mêmes
d'accord au même niveau que les autres
départements de france et la deuxième
chose juste une parenthèse c'est que le
fonds de péréquation que les communes
reverse une commune plus riches dans les
communes plus pauvres ces camions à
force d'ouvrir comme on plus riches
le fonds de péréquation il va servir à
quoi puisque on aura tous le même niveau
donc là je m'inquiète fortement comme de
suite en est loin on en est loin et il
faut voir l' usage qui est fait ces
fonds de péréquation york voilà la
deuxième chose c'est que
la genèse de ces rapprochements c'est
quand même le 92 qui est venu ton âme
1,78 donc pendant la période électorale
de qu'on peut être au courant mais en
tout cas ça c'est un autre débat moi je
ne sanctionne pas parce que on est
toujours en train de décrier qu' il ya
des strates qui sont en train de se
créer na 7 ces pannes strate
supplémentaire puisque l a4 qui
disparaissent donc c'est une fusion qui
a du sens un haut niveau de la société
d'économie mixte je parle ça donne du
poids aussi ça donne un certain confort
d' analyse sur territoire par rapport en
fin sur tous les territoires sur les
constructions sur les constructions
pardon
je pense qu'il faut
il faut laisser faire les élus ont un
droit de regard évidemment mais on ne
tue l'ordre décriées et là il se passe
quelque chose analysons regardons ce une
bonne chose c'est un premier pas moi
j'aurais mais derrière il y ait un plan
d'action beaucoup plus fort on sait pas
ce qui va se voir ce qui va se passer
avec évidemment que tous les acteurs
économiques élus associatifs un peu mais
au courant voilà que soit le sujet le
constat est le même c'est que les élus
locaux en tout cas à tous les échelons
on n'est pas assez consultés et qu'on
impose beaucoup de choses et là le
problème c'est que les élus locaux c'est
déjà des locaux qui m'ont fait que ces
deux départements qui appelle son
émotion et présenté les élus du
département
on dit go voilà je reviens juste un
point sur la réalité la ruralité je vois
pas comment les yvelines qui a eu un
certain nombre de choses de mise en
place c'est d'ailleurs cette semaine ou
la semaine dernière il ya eu un colloque
sur like les maires hier blanquer
ils sont pas là moi je pense que il ya
des bonnes choses sont faites sur le
département il ya des choses sur depuis
la loi un autre est en tout cas de leurs
propres structures régaliennes des
choses à faire ne pas oublier de bien
fibres et l'ensemble du département et
là je te rejoins tu me rejoins la
ruralité ne l'oublions pas c'est parce
qu'on agriculteurs qu'on n'a pas le
droit d'avoir blues et pis c'est souvent
le grand oublié depuis tendez bien
d'accord en développement il ya des
pinceaux des plans au niveau des pays et
c'est bon c'est un choix moi je pense
que faut faire une vraie analyse il faut
pas décrier sans argent ils ont fermé
une pépite c'est sûr département je
pense qu'il ya une analyse globale qui
est fait vous regardez sur sur un
spectre beaucoup plus large voilà on va
s'arrêter là juste ce que vous retenez
vous de l'actualité locale ou nationale
au niveau national on parle beaucoup de
la primaire par exemple est-ce que ça
c'est un sujet qui vous intéressait ces
derniers jours ça ne vous intéresse
beaucoup on a une il ya une fascination
en france pour un homme ou une femme
providentielle on cherche le ou la
personne qui va régler tous les
problèmes y en a pas si on regarde les
sondages alors pour l'instant il y en a
pas et puis surtout le problème de la
primaire c'est que c'est un petit peu la
course c'est la course à aller balancer
le truc qui va qui va rameuter les
abstentionnistes lors on vise pas trop
les abstentionnistes ça je pense que ça
se fera plutôt avec les candidats de
chaque parti une fois qu'ils seront
désignés et puis on a vu enfin moi ce
que je retiens et c'est dans le cadre de
la primaire on a un ancien président de
la république qui s'appelait en 2007 moi
petit français de sang mêlé et qui vient
expliquer aux gens déjà réécrire
l'histoire en expliquant qu'à partir du
moment où on devient français nos
ancêtres deviennent gaulois mot pour mot
revient sur l'une des polémiques des
biens non mais c'est assez péri parce
que ça montre ça montre que ce que vient
de pays on s'occupe plus des problèmes
on a six millions et demi de chômeurs on
a eu un million et demi de pauvres on a
deux cent mille élèves qui sortent
chaque année du système scolaire sans
formation sans qualification sans
diplôme on a un paysan qui se suicident
tous les deux jours et on vient nous
parler de ce que nous achetons soir on
vient nous parler de l'identité de ci de
ça c'est les gens veulent qu'on règle
leurs problèmes donc cette course qui
est en train de se faire entre deux
trois quatre cinq égaux mais on regarde
le cercle ans à la déclaration à la
petite fille la petite phrase luc
miserait dans l'actualité ce que vous
retenez ce soit locale ou nationale mais
aucun dossier oui
moi je voudrais alertés quand même sur
le danger du front national front
national qui dit sans arrêt
ben on a tout essayé
donc maintenant faut nous essayer nous
non mais oh on les a essayé déjà mois
ils ont été au gouvernement à la solde
des nazis pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'étaient eux il y avait des
milices qui existait c'était les milices
d'extrême droite donc il faut rafraîchir
la mémoire et moi j'ai parlé du front
national je l'aurais laissé vos
responsabilités aussi à vous les médias
le rappeler qui sont ces gens là la
dernière affiche qui nous sortent la
france apaisée avec l'extrême droite le
front national marine le pen pour pour
le coup va vous dire que ne sont plus
l'extrême droite que c'est pas demain
mais
ça c'est un d'histoire mais la réalité
c'est que l'extrême droite presse
l'extrême droite quand elle va
s'acoquiner avec l'extrême droite
autrichienne elle est bien avec
l'extrême droite autrichienne
etc etc donc ça il faut un rappeler ces
choses là et de rappeler aussi que en
termes économiques parce que les
problèmes que vous soulevez leur
solution elle est économique et c'est là
où je m'oppose au libéral financiers
mais oui il faut développer l'économie
le libéral financier grangrène le
développement économique a dit le front
national n'est pas libéral ça sent la
non cela n'est pas libérale mais le
front national se déclare nationale
capitaliste on a besoin de paix et de
sensibiliser les gens sur la tolérance
et sur le vivre ensemble renault logan
est forcément vous allez vouloir réagir
puisqu'il était question de libéralisme
mais aussi mondial maintenant que vous
vous retenez l'actualité et la culture
j'ai pas arrêté là j'ai plein de choses
à retenir jeu de trois choses évidemment
les primaires et on parle des primaires
de droite les prieurs de gauche j'ai
hâte de voir aussi parce que mon avis ça
va être bien croustillant je rejoins
marc lerouge sur un point c'est que a
rétorqué petites phrases et
la récupération systématique
je crois que pour moi il y à vraiment
avant lui répondre avec nous en même
temps le candidat
fillon qu'un programme assez ficelé et
mariton voilà mais
oui non mais bon voilà à abalessa
promise isme ceci bien sûr sûr sûr
le sur le fond on des primaires je crois
que il est temps de se mettre au travail
je pars le candidat et puis de mettre un
petit peu
au vert dès des médias et puis qui
bossent correctement ils ont tous des
qualités voilà mais faisons en tout cas
moi je me rassembleraient derrière un
candidat très clairement parce qu'on
peut pas laisser la france dans quel
qu'il soit c'est pas possible voilà le
deuxième point juste un petit clin petit
clin d'oeil à jacques chirac voilà parce
que je trouve que c'est un on peut aimer
ou pas aimé la politique qu'il a menée
je trouve que c'est un président sur la
politique extérieure qui a été
remarquable voilà je je souhaite pas qui
se passe dans l'oubli la grande anse que
tu en voilà
s'arrêter là
du premier café politique dans cette
nouvelle formule pour réagir sur
l'actualité à travers cette revue de
presse on se retrouve très bientôt sur
tv fils pour un nouveau numéro merci à
outrance
[Musique]